it took a dark turn but it's not
necessarily even the dark use I'm
talking about awesome
yeah like you out in the street [ __ ] but
just the same when you're going to talk
to these [ __ ] agents and managers and
[ __ ]
they could promise you the world they
don't rob you with guns they rob you
with words and the papers and [ __ ]
that's some Jadakiss by the way they do
that it's not everybody's a [ __ ]
shark breath some of my [ __ ] get you
with the knife some get you with the
pain bro you got got like on the on the
pen yeah everybody is but that's part of
the game though knowing knowing your
work if you you don't never know what
these people made off of this [ __ ] you
just know what you agree to right right
what can I just to keep it maybe towards
comedians more cuz that's the world
where and it's like what are what are
some maybe red flags we can keep an eye
out for from mistakes or lessons you've
had to learn the red flags don't be out
here trusting people don't be believing
this [ __ ] man don't if it sounds good
too good to be true it is man mmm you
know I mean nobody is out here looking
for your best interest and don't nobody
give a [ __ ] about your feelings Sony you
learned that [ __ ] the more you can the
better you can understand it the person
you rat your homie it might be your dog
you might have anything bruh
but don't never think that somebody's
gonna do something for you just because
they [ __ ] with you nobody it's all it's
all the business man and you can see you
start to see it once you get start
working it like business they don't give
a [ __ ] about who you think is funny or
whatever they gonna put whoever on this
show because that's what they doing is
their club they hired you but they had
these other [ __ ] - oh what
other business advice could you share i
got seen invest in yourself and find and
find another way find more than one way
to get paid don't just think don't just
get paid off telling jokes
people steal jokes all the time and the
people not gonna check to see who wrote
it they don't give a [ __ ]
they just know who excuse me they just
laughed at it because that's what was
available at the time
thank you oh [ __ ] who came from how old
is showcase none of that to get your
money and don't never worry about what
somebody else doing you might get you
might get hired and be doing the exact
same [ __ ] and these [ __ ]
standing right beside you got fired got
paid five times more than you just
because they asked for and you didn't
cuz they had the right infrastructure
set up they handle business they had the
right manager at the right agent and
they got what they asked for
so that plays a big part into it your
team right yeah you gotta like you can't
be successful by yourself man see is
nice and you gotta look out for yourself
but then you can't be successful by
yourself nobody gets successful by
yourself no wedding you start looking
around and paying attention to how
people get into the industry the the
industry industry it's always somebody
else who got them in there somebody
uncle was a producer or they dad was a
wrote a Motown song you know saying you
never know the connection is you your
name will get you a whole lot further
than your talent will your reputation
precedes you
being funny is just a that's just one of
the 10 things you got to do to get just
to be in the conversation and you can't
you can't just be fly-by-night funny you
gotta be consistently funny
it's people who I at the top of the game
who wanna [ __ ] with you but they just
want to see how you handle the next
three years see how you develop and what
kind of sense you have in the next year
so where you at can you stay in there a
lot of people come and go can you stay
hot like getting hot is easy cuz
everybody know you you jump you do magic
every night like where did he come from
right and then you get in that position
where it's like now you expect it to
create man
really a magician it's a great analogy
yeah it's the back like [ __ ]
wanna be in that spot but then when you
get in that spot and you got to do that
hour and a half after everybody in the
club just came and did they best [ __ ]
can you do it are you made of that
really made of man it's the third show
of the night you can't you do three a
night
that's what headliners do can you come
on stage and say [ __ ] you I'm out here
wait wait your improv [ __ ] it are you
off the cup or you can only tell jokes
that you wrote you might be a headliner
but you might what if you only got
exactly one hour of jokes to tell yeah
word for word
how do you freestyle like what is what
is the technique behind it cuz I'll try
sometimes but then if one thing missus I
may start to doubt and then I'll start
to work backwards but I've seen
potential in it but I you know I I end
up tucking my tail and running oh you
can't do that bro when you telling jokes
you don't wait for this crowd to approve
this [ __ ] it's funny you tell the joke
like you tell that [ __ ] with the same
conviction as you tell your joke that
you know as a banger because it's not
the joke best one is you you got to be a
funny person that's why I always wonder
how some people made it to you know this
long because they're not funny people
they're not funny at school and that
funny at work they weren't funny growing
up they never make nobody they never
made me laugh and all these years I've
known them like what is it that you're
doing how are you substantive yeah yeah
yeah who is booking this [ __ ]
how do they have a demand maybe they
have a good team exactly you could some
people do so it's how you say your joke
it's cuz you can get a lot caught up in
that right that's what I'm saying right
you have to detach yourself from I'm a
comedian here's a joke
that's so cookie cutter it's not being a
comedian
it's not the joke comedians make [ __ ]
funny the [ __ ] no you don't mean you
don't and making something funny doesn't
mean going onstage a bunch of times and
saying that [ __ ] and trying to figure
out to make it funny like a comedian is
the type of person who can be going into
an audition and might say to say one
word one word wrong 50 times but it's
funny every time they [ __ ] up
that's a comedian now a comic can sit at
home all day write jokes flip channels
and do little interpretations of what
this comedian said a little word flip in
there but that's all prepared [ __ ] they
do their impression of a comedian they
put all black on little goofy ass hat
and want to tell jokes were we mic
standing a stool because that's what
they're the essence of comedy but
they're not funny people you know some
people just don't have that natural
spark they can deliver a joke or they
can say some [ __ ] somebody wrote for him
but they not funny people so it's
different skill sets just maybe some a
better joke writer and not as good
improviser right that's just like saying
you just I'll use instruments all the
time presence is like saying you're a
dope-ass trumpet player but you can only
play a song if you got the music you
don't really know how to play that
[ __ ] you know really know how to
play that [ __ ] if you you know I'm
saying you see people play basketball
something [ __ ] a great
basketball players and they're good like
any other to any other court you put
them on there I'm [ __ ] amazing but
then you put them on court with LeBron
and [ __ ] Steph Curry and KD and they
look like children giving them saying
they're not built for that they body
really physically not built for that bro
he's like you just not made for this
[ __ ] you're the best point guard in the
league but you can never be a [ __ ]
small forward you'll never be a sinner
but then it's some [ __ ] who you
can put them on the court and you don't
even have to tell him what to do
some place some people just naturally
gifted bo Jackson's Deion Sanders
[ __ ] you know I'm saying the
challenge is [ __ ] proceed to Odell
Beckham's they could do any [ __ ]
thing birth and it is any good at it
if they're not good at it they're at
least good enough at it to captivate you
and make you watch them not be good at
it so you gotta have the self belief -
man let's kind of play into it that
confidence seems the longer I've been
doing comedy you know I've been doing it
over eight years now and it seems like
confidence can really Drive the audience
response yeah man if you can make people
like you don't matter what you say cuz
they like you they want you they want
people like you they treat you different
because you give them something and you
give them a feeling it's happiness if
you can make people happy [ __ ] what you
do [ __ ] the jokes that you told they'll
come see you a hundred times because you
make them happy
its atmosphere mmm do you acknowledge
them you talk to people different that's
the part about that's the part when you
can keep find out what makes people like
you that's what I make you a star it's
what Kevin Hart is winning so hard right
now he found out how to make people like
him he's unlikable do you want to see
him win you celebrate his victories with
him cuz he make you feel like you're a
part of them so find out what people
like about you right it might not
necessarily be the jokes it might be
your stupid Anna's pants
you look boyish grin or your voice it
just might like you cuz you were tall
[ __ ] but it might like you cuz
you're a pretty fat [ __ ]
you're just a flat person you smell good
you carry yourself different you got a
different swag your delivery you got an
accent from where you from they don't go
back to you though man what you gotta
find like this is my best advice find a
highlighter and use it on yourself like
if you a woman with some big-ass titties
let people know you know you got them
[ __ ] so you got big brown ass or
whatever for holidays are your weapons
if you could sing if you can do an
impression you can sound just like a
[ __ ] these are all talents you
bring to the stage cuz they can only get
that [ __ ] from you boom and you have a
lot of different talents man how are you
planning on using these going forward